[Music]
by the time we get to the end of the
biden administration term
i feel it would be time for me
to step down from this position
those are the words
as reported by politico of the most
powerful politician in america these
last two years
one of the most dishonest power mad
wackos to ever hold office in our
country
the one and only
dr
fauci
i'm not taking credit for this wonderful
turn of events it is true
that dr fauci abruptly stopped his
years-long ubiquitous tv appearances
almost immediately
after scores of political candidates and
members of congress signed on to my
public health protection pledge to
investigate and defund the fed
bureaucrat that's true it is true
that fauci remained in relative hiding
as my documentary series fauci unmasked
came out and chronicled his well-known
his well-hidden rather career of failure
incompetence and deceit
but it is also true that many other
people deserve credit as well for
helping to chase this tyrannical goblin
out of power i'm thinking of rand paul
in particular others as well
but the people who deserve the most
credit
for finally possibly
ridding our nation
of the political pox named anthony fauci
are the voters
because that's the real reason fauci
might step down yes he's old yes he's
failed yes he's been exposed but none of
those reasons are why he's stepping down
fauci has admitted as much himself
the reason that fauci is stepping down
is political
he is going to step down when the
democrats are out of power
in his own words
they're going to try and come after me
probably less so if i'm not in the job
they refers to us of course
fauci's timetable for retirement is not
based on any milestone on covid or any
other virus it isn't based on any
particular age he will reach it is based
on whenever biden leaves office that's
the best part of it all
even more exciting than fauci finally
going away one hopes very far away maybe
to to a far-off island like saint helena
what is even more exciting than that is
his reasoning
fauci is bad in a lot of ways
but no one can deny fauci is a brilliant
politician and fouchy can feel the way
the wind is blowing and he knows that
the wind is in our sails and if he isn't
careful that wind is going to knock him
over and sweep him away i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from great
impression of a hot dog what a name
comment is i feel like michael's comment
section today is filled with people like
me women who knew that things were not
quite right with their cycle and body
chemistry after getting the vaccine
relieved to now have a place to air it
out
me had a baby 14 months ago and haven't
had a period yet i love my husband so
much and i want to have another baby
with him but i'm starting to fear that
we can't well on that second point
that's not unusual for a woman's cycle
not not to return for
a year or more after having a baby
breastfeeding i think plays into that a
little bit so that part's not
necessarily unusual but to your broader
point that you knew something was wrong
when you took the
fouchy algae and you knew something was
changing with your menstrual cycle but
you were being told by all the
establishment types that you it was
impossible
ignore it don't pay attention to your
lying eyes and now you find out oh wait
a second it's true they're admitting it
it affects 42 of women and you're saying
you're really glad that you can air that
out in the comments section do you know
the real place
where you're allowed to air out all of
your legitimate fears about the stuff
that they're calling you a conspiracy
theory theorist for right now
nine months in the future that's the
place right now the stuff that they are
calling a wild kooky crazy
conspiracy theory that's threatening to
public health and it's killing people
in nine months that will be the
mainstream so just i patience is a
virtue i know it's very frustrating but
that's the way that our system works
right now we need better people in the
system when you want to hire better
people you got to check out zip
recruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
knowles summer is upon us people are
traveling i've been traveling have you
ever thought that all the people that
make a great trip
so great i'm thinking of the hotel
concierge i'm thinking of the tour guide
if you're going to some
wild destination i'm thinking of the
chef at the cool restaurant the
bartender you strike up a conversation
with you know outstanding talent is
crucial for a successful business if you
are hiring you can find talent for roles
such as these and more at zip recruiter
when you try it for free at zip
recruiter dot com slash knowles zip
recruiter uses powerful matching
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job you easily
review these recommended candidates you
invite your top choices to apply
ziprecruiter's got a complete suite of
tools that makes it easy to filter
review and rate your candidates four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day that's why ziprecruiter is
the number one rated hiring site based
on g2 satisfaction ratings as of january
1st of this year travel to this easy to
remember web destination right now
ziprecruiter.com
knowles that is where you can try zip
recruiter for free zip recruiter.com
k-w-l-e-s zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
fouchy knows which way the wind is
blowing
this is actually why he disappeared
pretty much immediately when the public
health protection pledge was making the
rounds when the documentary came out
when rand paul was really hammering him
at the senate he disappeared because he
knew oops
i'm not as popular as i once was oops i
think the jig is up oops okay and then
he went into witness protection and
stopped appearing on tv well now i think
he knows that that decline in popularity
is terminal because fouchy's
power is tied to the democrats and the
democrats are going down joe biden's
economic approval rating right now
is not just lower than donald trump's
worst economic approval rating
biden's economic approval rating is
double digits worse than donald trump's
worst ever economic approval rating this
is according to cnbc cnbc not exactly a
right-leaning outlet the all-america
economy survey
recorded biden's economic approval
rating
dropping five points since april the
last time they took the survey was in
april he's now down five points since
then 30 percent of americans approve of
joe biden's economic performance trump's
lowest number was 41 percent
that's an 11 percentage point delta
and that's important because who's the
leading republican candidate right now
to go up against biden or whoever the
nominee is in 2024 it's trump you might
prefer desantis desantis is a great
candidate you might prefer ted cruz i
think ted cruz is a great candidate you
might prefer i don't know nikki haley or
mike pompeo or someone else but it's
just a statistical fact donald trump is
by far at the head of the pack right now
and so you're putting these two guys up
head to head one's got at the worst a 41
economic approval rating the other one's
got a 30 economic approval rating
that's going to be very hard for the 30
guy to overcome
why is this happening the biden team
doesn't seem able to figure out why
biden's numbers are so low they
they can't blame themselves they can't
accept responsibility for anything jill
biden was just speaking to a bunch of
donors in nantucket she said you know
it's just the reason that our numbers
are so low it's every single thing other
than us she says
he's just had so many things thrown his
way who would have ever thought
about what happened roe v wade well
maybe we saw it coming but we still
didn't believe it the gun violence in
this country is absolutely appalling we
didn't see the war in ukraine coming
right she lists this litany of all the
terrible things that are the reason why
everything is collapsing under biden and
why his approval ratings are going down
the next question you got to ask is
why didn't you see it coming
especially when we're talking about the
war in ukraine which is largely
responsible for the spike in gas prices
which is causing the spike in all of the
prices which is
probably the single biggest problem with
biden's administration
why didn't you guys see this coming we
saw it coming
we predicted this stuff on this show
we predicted this stuff i have a show
with ted cruz called verdict we
predicted it on that show laid out
exactly how it was going to happen it
was no big secret
joe biden
came in and eased sanctions on russia
and gave russia an oil pipeline called
nordstrom 2 and by green lighting that
pipeline
anybody with two brain cells to rub
together knew that putin was going to be
freed up to enter ukraine
this was no big secret
the president of ukraine said that
vladimir zelinski who now the democrats
are saying is winston churchill and he's
the greatest man in the world and we
need to give him whatever he wants well
okay why didn't you give him the
economic sanctions on russia when he
asked for it they could have stopped the
invasion
oh we didn't see this coming yeah i know
you didn't see a lot of things coming
you didn't see the potential over ruling
of roe v wade you should have seen this
coming for 50 years because roe v wade
was a ridiculous court decision and the
pro-life movement has been steadily
gaining steam for half a century
probably should have seen that one
coming
the gun violence in this country what
are you talking about the gun violence
in this country
guns have always been a major factor of
american life
gun violence is not
not exactly increasing it it kind of
depends on what you're looking at if
you're if you're talking specifically
about crime in the inner cities yeah
that's spiking that's going through the
roof wonder why that's happening might
it have something to do with the fact
that democrats for two to three years
now have been calling to abolish the
police and defund the police and
installing radical prosecutors and and
district attorneys who let the criminals
off the hook you think that's got
something to do with the epidemic of
violence in this country and crime rate
going up who could have seen that coming
i don't know anybody with eyes and a
brain
we just guys it's not our fault we just
didn't see it coming well yeah that's
the problem biden that's why you and the
rest of us are in the mess that you have
put us in right now you know what else
they didn't see coming they didn't see
that conservatives would push back
this is the most delightful clip i have
seen on cable news in a very long time
the mayor of washington dc muriel bowser
just went on cbs's face the nation on
the sunday show and she she showed up on
tv to complain
that the governor of texas
is sending a bunch of illegal aliens on
charter buses to her city so the
democrats have been promoting illegal
immigration the most insanely high
illegal immigration numbers that we've
ever seen in this country two million a
year plus coming across that border
illegally and the democrats are fine
with it because they say yeah they're
all going to go to texas
they're going to be in arizona new
mexico it's no big deal forget about it
we're not going to have to worry about
it in martha's vineyard in nantucket in
washington d.c
so greg abbott he says okay hey you know
what here's a good use of taxpayer money
we're going to buy a few kind of cheap
bus tickets we're going to put all you
illegals on the bus we're going to send
you up to dc and then those politicians
who are causing the problem they can
deal with it and muriel bowser says whoa
whoa whoa man
what are you doing to me
the washington post reported last week
that homeless shelters in dc were
filling up
and groups are getting overwhelmed by
these buses that the governors of texas
and and arizona are sending here full of
migrants
how significant is this influx how many
people
well this is a very significant issue we
have for sure called on the federal
government
to work across state lines to prevent
people from really being tricked into
getting on buses
we think they're largely asylum seekers
who are going to final destinations that
are not washington d.c
i worked with the white house to make
sure that fema provided a grant to a
local organization
that is providing services to folks
but i fear that they're being tricked
into nationwide
bus trips when their final destinations
are places all over the united states of
america
yeah that's the problem we're going to
make the final destination for the
illegal immigration that you're
encouraging we're going to make it your
town and your home that's that's the
they're yeah they are being tricked
they're being tricked by democrats to
come into this country illegally and now
you're complaining
that we are taking
the those that process of illegal
immigration to its logical conclusion
and saying okay dc you want this illegal
immigration fine it's coming to your
home
no you can't we're trying to trick the
immigrants and the republicans you can't
you can't play a trick on us in return
yes we can the republicans can get
aggressive here because the wind is at
our sales and the democrats don't have
very much that they can do right now
they are being out maneuvered in your
face republicans are looking very very
good right now sometimes republicans
they want to play it safe think about
mitt romney 2012. i'm not going to talk
about any issues that people actually
care about i'm just going to talk about
how the economy is bad
so you know that's kind of everyone
everyone knows the economy is bad and
they don't like that and i'm going to
talk about maybe we're going to cut
taxes a little bit but i'm not going to
talk about any of the issues that are
really
driving people the cultural issues the
social issues the issues that tug on the
heartstrings a lot more than the
marginal corporate tax rate
part of the reason romney couldn't do
that by the way is because he invented
obamacare but that was one of the
weaknesses of that nomination he is the
kind of
nice
polite republican who doesn't he just
doesn't want to rock the boat he just
wants to kind of sneak into office and
that almost always fails then you've got
the in-your-face republicans
you've got people like donald trump
who say this country's going to hell in
a handbasket you weirdos are doing all
kinds of crazy stuff and we hate it and
we're going to stop you from doing it
stop protesting the american flag stop
transiting the kids stop pushing your
weird stuff on the country build a giant
wall stop flooding the country with
foreigners because you think it's going
to give you an electoral advantage just
cut it out you people are are
jerks for doing that we're not going to
let you do it anymore so that's that's
donald trump
which
which strategy has been successful
especially in recent years obviously
it's the more aggressive strategy
because republicans and americans more
broadly have had enough we know that the
libs have gone too far when we talk
about the 2024 republican nomination
a lot of people right now think the
divide is between donald trump and ron
desantis
with some other people suggesting maybe
uh senator cruz or nikki haley or mike
pompeo or mike pence some people have
suggested or whatever some other people
too
and
already people have taken really firm
sides here and they're
extremely harsh partisans for one of
those candidates over the others but the
fact remains there's a statistical fact
here donald trump is way at the top of
the heap he's up something like 40
points
why is he up so high a lot of
conservatives will say why is trump
doing better than desantis
trump foisted the vaccine on us and ron
desantis stood up against uh promoting
the vaccine too much uh trump didn't
reopen the country by easter and he gave
dr fauci a lot of power ron desantis
stood up against the kovitz stuff and
that there's no question covid is
desantis's great strength and trump's
biggest weakness here there's no
question about that and then they look
on all the other issues they say maybe
here desantis is a little more
conservative well maybe here trump is a
little bit more effective and
conservative boom boom boom they go back
and forth and back and forth well look
and here's one of the greatest arguments
in favor of trump
trump got roe v wade overruled oh my
gosh it's the most important
political achievement of my lifetime
of multiple generations probably wow
that's pretty amazing okay so they're
going back and forth on the horse race
everyone is ignoring probably the most
pertinent fact for the 2024 presidential
race and it was
demonstrated in a clip that was going
viral around the internet yesterday it
was a clip from one of trump's old
speeches mashed up with a little bit of
music just take a listen they want to
ban straws
has anybody ever tried those paper
stores they're not working
right
they want to ban straws i said well you
know i've had
a couple of
meals at mcdonald's etc over the years
wendy's friend of mine owns wendy's i'll
give it a plug right burger king
so they want to ban straws i said oh
really what about the cartons what about
the plates
what about the knives and the spoons and
the plastic
oh they're okay but the straws are going
to be
[Applause]
has anybody ever tried juicing the new
shorts made out of paper right
it disintegrates as you're drinking if
you have a nice guy like this guy
this would have no chance
you all hear about this what's the deal
with these paper stores
this is
trump's secret weapon and i think it
very well could be decisive in 2024 it
certainly was decisive in 2016.
trump is so
freaking entertaining he's so
funny the man is captivating he has star
quality
okay and i'm not saying that's a good
thing and i'm not saying it's a bad
thing i'm just
i'm just telling you what it is
he has that and it's why in 2016 donald
trump blew everybody else off the stage
donald trump did not have the most
conservative record in 2016 far from it
didn't matter he ended up being the most
conservative president of
my lifetime in a very very long time
but
not in 2016 he's just he's just a magnet
for attention he just
commands your attention
can ron desantis do that i don't know
maybe he can he hasn't
tried at the national level yet so maybe
he can maybe he can't that remains a big
question mark can the other candidates i
don't know maybe maybe not but what i
know is donald trump is a network tv
star and he's so freaking funny that he
could do a stand-up routine
pretty much any night of the week he
could probably go for two hours south
park made the same observation about him
in 2016 when south park was making jokes
about donald trump they always
positioned him as a kind of stand-up
comedian
when when they would depict him giving a
political speech they'd have the
spotlight come on him they'd have a
stool he'd light up a cigarette he said
you guys hear about this you guys hear
about this thing
what's the deal with my wife or whatever
so
that's really important because people
who are listening to the show are
probably very high information voters
you consume a lot of political media you
know where the candidates stand on the
issues you're focused you're hyper
vigilant on all of the
different domestic and foreign matters
most voters are not like that
most voters are not like that
not even
i'm not even trying to disparage most
voters most voters just have other
things to do and they're just not
focused and it doesn't interest them
that much and so they're paying a
relatively low amount of attention to
the political scene and that guy is
going to command your attention
more so i think than most other
candidates if if a candidate wants to
beat trump in a primary you've got to
figure out a way to get over that some
of the candidates tried to do that in
2016 it didn't work marco rubio you
remember he tried to do his don rickles
routine for a while he said damn trump
is so funny how come he okay and he then
rubio did that whole routine about how
trump has small hands and that implied
that he had tiny genitals and it
completely backfired i mean the guy just
stepped on a rake and trump squashed him
with it because you you can't really
fake it
you've got that star quality or you
don't you've got you've you've honed
that skill or you haven't
people have to to
people have to take on that
particular strength if they want to be
trump in 2024.
and trump's going to be even funnier in
2024 because the libs are providing so
much material
there's a third grade teacher just went
viral on tick tock as a queer third
grade teacher who's got crazy colored
hair and is going off about her sexual
desires on tick tock but she says look
she doesn't make a big deal out of it
i am an openly queer teacher no i don't
stand in front of my elementary students
and be like
i like women but i wear a bi flag watch
band
buy flag bracelets
in my classroom i keep a rainbow flag
it's got mickey mouse on it because i
love mickey but it's got
a rainbow my kids know what it means
this is me telling them i am a safe
place to talk
without
making a big deal out of being queer
side note i shaved the side of my head
love it
okay going back to the main topic anyway
so because i am openly queer my students
trust me especially my queer students i
teach
fifth grade this next school year i've
been teaching fourth grade for the last
four years
anyway right now i'm teaching summer
school and i have third graders
like i said i wear these bracelets to
let them know i'm a safe space
two students two third grade students
came to me and asked me to use they them
pronouns
isn't that great i i translate a couple
of my third grade students because i
don't make a big deal out of it i don't
i don't broadcast that i'm queer you
know i mean i wear multiple bracelets
that are basically billboards that say
i'm queer and i dye my hair like the
queer thing and i got that haircut that
all the queer people got in 2013 or 2014
and i whenever students come up to me
and mention anything about sex i love to
talk to them about it and i really
indulge those conversations but i don't
make a big deal out of it right
if that's not a big deal what what would
making a big deal of it be would she
would she jump out of a cake every
morning in her and do a little strip
tease in her third grade classroom i
don't know how you could make a bigger
deal yeah i've got the flag up in my
classroom
and you know i give all of my students a
dose of lupron before we start that's
for snack time i give them some
cross-sex hormones but i don't really
make a big deal out of it right
these people are beyond parody and it's
not just the conservatives who oppose
that it's the majority of americans and
republicans especially the funny ones
you're gonna have a field day with that
in 2022 and 2024. this week
we are celebrating the first anniversary
of our podcast morning wire in this
short period of time
it has become one of the top news
podcasts i suspect it's because morning
wire gives you only the news that you
need to know in 15 minutes or less
without the manufactured outrage so
check out warning wire on apple podcast
spotify daily wire plus or wherever you
listen to podcasts and while you're at
it check out the rest of our extensive
content library at dailywireplus.com
such as
fouchy unmasked that's our docu-series
hosted by yours truly in light of fouchy
maybe retiring this is a great way to
give him a fitting send-off i'd like to
give him a nice one-finger salute to
send him off another way to send them
off
check out the che voucher merch that is
left in my store at my store over at
dailywire.com we've got some really
primo fouchy merch i get it while you
still can right now you can get 35 off
your daily wire membership so head on
over to dailywireplus.com today we'll be
right back with a lot more
sometimes the lib sexual revolutionaries
are pretty funny like the looney tunes
who pratalana and tiktok
sometimes it's not so funny like when
the assistant secretary of health
richard levine who calls himself rachel
uh
explains how he plans to empower young
people by castrating them we really want
to to to to base our treatment and uh
and to affirm and to
uh support and empower these youth not
to limit their participation in
activities in sports and even uh limit
their ability to get gender affirmation
treatment in their state did you hear
that freudian slip at the beginning he
goes we really really want to debase our
treatment
you are debasing medical treatment
that's true i don't think he meant to
say that but certainly how it came out
and he says look we want to empower
people and we and we want them to be
able to get gender affirmation treatment
little kids
little kids getting pumped full of
puberty blockers and cross-sex hormones
and having their bodies mutilated
that's not so funny
we can laugh and make fun of the libs of
tik-tok and everything like that
it's great i mean that's what libs of
tik-tok is probably our favorite account
on twitter right because it just
highlights all those libs of tik-tok but
this is libs of
major government authority this is libs
of lots of political power to abuse your
children power that they are exercising
that's not so funny that's not going to
play very well in
november
there's a lot of confusion there's a lot
of sexual confusion and chaos going
around the culture and the reason it
keeps coming up the reason all these
videos keep going viral whether we're
talking about lips of tick tock or other
platforms the reason we're talking about
this is because the democrats and the
the radicals are focusing very very much
on sexual issues they have made sex the
focal point of their political agenda
and conservatives some conservatives at
least are reacting against that
ted cruz
got a ton of headlines a couple of days
ago because on the bonus segment of the
show that he and i host together he was
asked by our friend liz wheeler hey
senator what do you think about the
obergefell case that created a
constitutional right to same-sex
marriage redefined marriage and do you
think that was a good decision and cruz
gave the completely unobjectionable
answer he said well it was obviously
wrongly decided at the time unless you
believe that james madison intended to
redefine marriage
to include same-sex unions at a time
when that was completely unthinkable
then you would have to agree that it's
not in the constitution even if you like
it it's not in the constitution so they
played that clip
went viral all the libs clutched their
pearls
here's the fuller context though because
the
cruz made the constitutional point but
then he made a broader political point
about what's going to happen to marriage
in the future
in dobbs what the supreme court said
isro is different because it's the only
one of the cases that involves the
taking of a human life and that's
qualitatively different i agree with
that proposition
uh that is fundamentally different i
will say on a burgerfel
there is also when a court is
considering whether to overturn a
precedent
one of the factors that the court looks
to is reliance interest have people
relied on the previous precedent and
have they acted accordingly
and in the context of marriage look
you've got
a ton of people who who have entered
into gay marriages
and
it would be
more than a little chaotic for the court
to do something that somehow
disrupted those marriages that have been
entered into in accordance with the law
i think that would be
a factor that would uh
would counsel restraint that would with
that that the court would be concerned
about but to be honest i i don't think
this court has any appetite for
overturning any of these decisions
so there is the political analysis and i
think his political analysis is right by
the way
the constitutional analysis is same-sex
marriage is completely preposterous from
the standpoint of the constitution it's
just
it's ridiculous
but as a political matter the court's
not going to do anything about it
they're not going to overrule obergefell
there's no appetite on the court to do
that there are some considerations
that people have entered into these
same-sex marriages and so if you upended
that that would create some political
problems and it's just it's not going to
happen okay so i took a little poll on
twitter highly scientific poll on
twitter and the results
were fascinating
the question i asked was do you think
the government should recognize same-sex
marriage
four possible answers yes and i lean
left yes and i lean right no and i lean
left no and i lean right
now
most of the people who follow me are
conservative
so you only about
five or six percent of the respondents
lean left
and they were split even on the left
they were split two and a half percent
two and a half percent
said yes two and a half percent said no
that's kind of weird even on the left
there's this big split but then what
about the conservatives you would expect
the conservatives overwhelmingly to
oppose same-sex marriage right
no it was split about 50 50. there was a
slight advantage for the people who
don't think the government should
recognize same-sex marriage no eileen
wright was about 51 percent
yes eileen wright was about 42 percent
the even the conservatives are split on
this so to to
buttress ted cruz's now political
analysis here
gay marriage is not going anywhere
anytime soon
the court has at least something of a
legal argument as to why they wouldn't
want to overrule obergefell i don't
think a case would even make it up to
the supreme court it would be hard hard
to even think about how you could bring
a case that would bring this question
back to the the mind of the the justices
and
very few people want to overrule
same-sex marriage in america
very few people half of the
conservatives and maybe half of the
liberals but i i don't really think that
those numbers are so small i'm not sure
that that's really a reliable number but
at least talking about the conservatives
here
it's 50 50.
which doesn't
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
it doesn't make a lot of sense to me
because
if if you had done the same poll 10
years ago
the vast majority of people
would have said no the government
shouldn't recognize same-sex marriage
including the liberals they put it up
for a vote in california it failed
same-sex marriage
so how in just a period of seven years
has has same-sex marriage gains such
widespread acceptance and support
well it's because there's a fifth answer
that is was not included there was no
room for it in the poll which is oh i
don't care
i don't mind get the government out of
marriage entirely i don't want to think
about it come on it's no big deal forget
about it i don't really mind what how
does this affect me
now i i didn't include that answer in
the poll also because
government has always regulated marriage
everywhere at all times throughout human
history so that's not
just as a practical matter that's not a
real salute that's a utopian slogan
but what it really means and this is the
important lesson i don't even
bring it up to talk about same-sex
marriage what it really means is
there's an important fact of politics
which is that most people's political
views
don't make sense
that most people's political views don't
make sense
same-sex marriage is
the wokest thing ever
it is the most radical thing that we
have done in this country
ever
it's and it's not even close
abortion is less radical than same-sex
marriage cultures throughout human
history have practiced child sacrifice
and human sacrifice
it's horrible it's an extremely evil
thing
but it's not all that unusual
cultures throughout human history have
practiced eugenics going back to ancient
sparta and even further back all the way
up to the present
same-sex marriage is more radical than
transing the kids there have been
eunuchs throughout all of human history
again it's awful it's evil it's not very
nice
but
it's not all that unusual
to trans the kids even
same-sex marriage has never existed
anywhere same-sex marriage is more
radical even than those radical things
because it involves a redefinition of
the fundamental political institution
along the premise that there's no
difference between men and women
that is so
extremely radical and half of the
conservatives support that view now
and a lot of the conservatives don't
even think it matters oh who cares
it doesn't make any sense at all
the the conservatives oppose
transgenderism because men and women are
different
conservatives watch what is a woman
movie the matt walsh movie because men
and women are different it's so obvious
and yet
when it comes to the fundamental
political institution
conservatives throw that out the window
it's not just concern
most people's political views don't make
all that much sense think of your
liberal cousin
who's a vegan and we've all got a
liberal cousin who's a vegan and your
liberal cousin who's a vegan 99 times
out of 100.
999 times out of a thousand will support
abortion
won't eat meat
won't eat eggs won't even eat the
products of animals because we have to
be so nice to all the living creatures
but yes let's kill babies up until the
moment of birth
abortion on demand with that apology
that just doesn't make sense think about
the libs when it comes to the
environment
we can't burn fossil fuels that's really
bad for the environment we've got to get
off of fossil fuels and then the
conservatives propose nuclear energy
which is by far the most efficient clean
energy
that we've got available to us the lib
say no we don't want that either
we can't have oil pipelines in america
that's bad for the environment that's
why we need to support oil pipelines in
russia
that's why we need to get gas from iran
and saudi arabia does that make sense no
it doesn't make any sense
at all
but conservatives are like this too
conservatives fall into this trap too
think about what conservatives say with
abortion and ivf we were talking about
that this past week conservatives say
abortion is terrible because human life
begins at the moment of conception so we
need to ban abortion
but we need to allow ivf
which
produces lots of human embryos and then
either destroys them or freezes them in
perpetuity
hold on you're telling me that life
begins at conception that's why we've
got to get rid of abortion but light
life doesn't begin at conception when
we're talking about ivf that doesn't
make any sense and i know that a lot of
conservatives go along with that
same thing on same-sex marriage you're
telling me that it's so important we
need to defend our traditional values in
our traditional society
except for the fundamental political
institution the family we're going to
now fundamentally sever the connection
between family and nature
but but we still we need to defend
traditional values you would hear this
for years in republican speeches
especially in the 90s and 2000s the
first part of the republican speech
would be we need to defend our society
and the traditional institutions and the
civic associations and the family and
our good old american way of life
and
then you get to the second part of the
speech they'd say that's why we need
creative destruction and rampant
capitalism and innovation everywhere and
new technology and we need to just out
with the old in with the new and new new
new and let's make a lot more money and
hold on wait what was what about the old
keep the social mores and don't
change a lot of stuff and maintain our
traditional values
until you get to the second half of the
speech why do i bring this up it's not
to dunk on the libs it's not to dunk on
the conservatives it's not to say that
everybody's so stupid except for us
we're so smart aren't we folks it's not
to it's not to say that at all i'm sure
that
there are some problems in our political
philosophies too i bet there's some
things that we haven't totally thought
through as well
i'm making a descriptive
observation
i'm pointing out it is simply a fact
that most people's political views
don't make all that much sense
and so when you want to win a political
election
when you want to win a campaign when you
want to get something accomplished when
you want to get a law or a candidate
across the finish line
you've got to be clever about it you've
got to speak in a way
that will reach the greatest number of
people
but might not always make the most sense
this is why we talked about yesterday
ron desantis's line that he's that has
been extremely popular in florida he
says we need
education
not indoctrination
that line doesn't
really totally makes sense because
education and indoctrination are pretty
much the same thing
but but people kind of know what you're
getting at
when you say that sort of thing
okay people kind it
it
it pulls on the right strings and will
motivate people to go vote i mean you
just see it in the poll numbers for for
desantis
that's what conservatives are going to
have to do in order to win elections you
are not you are not going to make a ton
of progress on these issues by just
laying out the perfectly precise pure
argument okay
how did the pro-life movement do so well
over the last 50 years
is the pro-life movement just make
totally clear crystal clear arguments
they did i just don't think that was the
most persuasive part i think the most
persuasive part was showing people what
a sonogram looks like and showing people
what an abortion looks like
and showing people cute little babies
and that's just where people are and
that's where you've got to meet them on
these kinds of issues
because people know that something is
wrong in the sexual culture right now
and they know that the libs are focusing
on sex because it's powerful and they
they just they get that something's
wrong
so you've got to you've got to encourage
them in that here's
a great example of this
this is a shocking historic story just
came out of a women's prison a an inmate
a trans woman
inmate in the women's prison who's in
for manslaughter
has just been moved out of the prison
after she
knocked up two other women she
impregnated two other women there what a
time to be alive
we're living at a time where for the
first time in human history a woman
has impregnated other women what are the
odds isn't that so strange demi minor i
don't know what his real name is he's 27
years old just transferred out of the
edna mayhem correctional facility for
women in new jersey is serving a 30-year
sentence for manslaughter but he keeps
knocking up the inmates
we're not going to
win on on these issues especially issues
like transgenderism human sexuality the
the human person in our relation to our
citizens and the state we're not going
to win by just making pure boring
philosophical arguments
we've got to kind of work in the other
direction we've got to point to these
stories and say hey you see that you see
that husky dude in a dress knocking up
all the women in the prisons that's
wrong right we all know that that's
wrong okay so let's stop that and now
let's think why is that wrong
maybe that's wrong because he's not
really a chick maybe it's wrong because
men can't become chicks maybe that's
wrong because men and women are
different maybe men and women
are called to slightly different things
and they're not just completely
indiscernible and identical at all times
maybe we need to return to a kind of
more traditional normal way of viewing
men and women that has prevailed
everywhere throughout the entire history
of the world until about five seconds
ago here you've got to work
backwards
speaking of deranged women
a uh white lady is very very upset
at other white ladies and she's very
upset at other white ladies because she
and her fellow white ladies
have committed a truly evil and
atrocious act
they have given birth to white men
buckle in i'm going to get brutally
honest
the hand that rocks the cradle rules the
world
who created these monsters
we did
we birthed them
we nursed them
we read their little nursery rhymes and
sing the little songs
we taught them in their preschools in
their kindergartens and their first and
third grades
white women
craft their own gilded cage
and we do it
by raising little misogynistic
patriarchal tyrants
we raise the little boys
who grow up
to be the donald trumps
the mitch mcconnells
the greg locks of this world white women
raised them
now i hear you on the last sentence
when these little tyrants
grow up and abuse us and we speak out
about it yeah we're gonna be
institutionalized
yeah she's saying yeah they're gonna
call us crazy huh why would they ever
think we're crazy we just hate ourselves
and our kids
and she's got those eyes you can tell by
the eyes the eyes are usually a giveaway
this is the logical conclusion though
of the illogical i guess conclusion of
what the left is pushing
which is
a mother
despising her own
child
the politics of resentment
which starts out as just being about
everyone else i'm really good and
everyone else is really bad that
politics of resentment is going to come
back like a snake eating its own tail
and it's going to come back on a kind of
personal resentment she hates herself
because she's a white woman
and she even hates her own child
ties right into the politics of abortion
why does the left
not merely tolerate or encourage
abortion to some moderate degree why
does the left make a sacrament out of
abortion why is abortion the sacred
fundamental right according to the left
it's it's at the very heart of this
politics of resentment mother teresa
made this point 30 years ago in a speech
at the united nations she said abor i'm
paraphrasing slightly
she said abortion is the greatest evil
in the world
and the reason is if a mother
can kill her own child
there is no limit to the evil and
depravity that will go on if a mother
can kill her own child and this video of
this lady is we are
the we should hate ourselves because we
have committed the great evil action of
giving birth and creating life so we
obviously need to hate our own children
that is the level
of animus
that you see on on the left you also see
this is the level of animus against
white men the only group in america that
you can legally discriminate against
is white men
white people broadly to some extent
asian people because they get lumped in
as white people for some reason and men
kind of broadly but specifically at that
apex at the very tippy top of the
intersectional pyramid
it's
straight white men who know that they're
men and beyond legal discrimination in
college admissions and work it's the
only group that you're socially allowed
to constantly demean and insult
you can't do that about black people
can't do it about hispanic people can't
do it about asian people can't do it
about women can't do it about
homosexuals can't do it about any other
kind of sexual identities other than
white men
straight
white men who know that they're men
that's the group that you can so vilify
that even their mothers are now
encouraged to vilify them
but before we go i've got to get to a
story about positive masculinity you
always hear about toxic masculinity
and i think this guy was a white guy too
i'm not totally sure he's definitely a
dude
a good guy with a gun saving a lot of
lives in indiana the reason you're not
going to hear about this story very much
is because it contradicts the libs
narrative
there was a mass shooter at a mall in
greenwood indiana
he fired into a civilian crowd in uh at
the food court
he killed three people he wounded two
people but before he could kill 20
people or 30 people a good guy with a
gun elisha dicken 22 years old
was there and he was carrying his gun
because of indiana's constitutional
carry law so only because of that
that great law that was passed in
indiana
you had po culture downstream of
politics here the guy was carrying his
gun he pulls his gun out he shoots the
mass shooter
and sadly the mass shooter already
killed three people he could have killed
ten times that
could have killed even more than that
you saw what happened in uvalde where
the cops didn't show up on time they did
show up and they didn't do anything
the good guy with a gun
absolutely vindicated you are not going
to hear that story one last little tiny
final story there are some republican
senators right now being led by senator
joni ernst who are proposing making june
protect life month it's the month of
life because that was the month that roe
v wade was overruled in the dobbs
decision i think this is a great idea
conservatives need to engage in the
culture we need
liturgical celebrations we need to
celebrate things all states always do
that it's kind of religious it's very
public and every culture has always had
these sorts of things public festivals
sacred days feast days right now we've
got a
sacred month quote unquote and it's
pride month in june and we have all sort
we have the mon black history month
women's month this month that month we
have traditional holidays the fourth of
july thanksgiving we have these kind of
sacred days we absolutely need one for
life you can't back away from the
culture you can't say oh well just keep
my values out of your life or this
that's that's not how politics works
it's not how it's ever worked and the
wind is at our sales here and people are
going to be supportive of this and
furthermore when we
when we act in a certain way when we
revere things when we venerate things
when we worship
together that affects the culture it
affects how we think and how we believe
there's this idea it's a catholic idea
lex orandi lex credendi lex vivendi the
way that we worship affects the way that
we believe it affects our actual views
of things and it affects the way that we
live the wind is at our sales dr fauci
knows it
you all know it so let's push ahead and
let's get let's get the month of life
exalted in june so that maybe that will
move the way we believe and the way that
we live in the right direction i'm
michael nola's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor-in-chief and co-host of
morningwire on today's episode democrats
attempt to penalize and defund pregnancy
centers the fundraising battle between
the dems and gop heats up and parents
sue tiktok for allegedly leading to the
death of their children
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire